what if we could stop extreme weather
events the expansion of deserts and
rising sea levels scientists are already
devising techniques to intervene in the
Earth's natural systems it's a field
known as geoengineering it's basically a
suitable approach maybe not the best but
appropriate we humans have caused global
warming through our activities and so
now through our activities we can also
counteract it one example of
geoengineering the greenhouse gas carbon
dioxide is filtered directly out of the
air using a chemical process the co2 is
then pumped underground where it can no
longer harm the climate the swiss
company Clym works are among the
pioneers in this field but as yet
they're only able to filter rather
modest amounts of carbon dioxide out of
the air 900 tons a year equivalent to
the co2 produced by some 200 cars
annually potential business partners
remain skeptical as the scans cloud
hasn't gotten to the point where people
come to us and immediately agree to
partner with us there's lots of
discussion and talking vena despacio the
company is currently developing its
technology at an Icelandic power plant
in a pilot project the captured carbon
dioxide is being pumped 1,000 meters
below ground
the idea is to store it there
permanently a visionary technology which
is now grabbing political attention so
sometimes in the world small beginnings
turns into a monument of scientific
transformation for the good of the world
and I believe very strongly that's
what's happening here today storing one
ton of co2 underground costs several
hundred euros and Klein works is still
waiting for the really big customers to
come along
that could be a supermarket chain that
set itself the goal of becoming climate
neutral by 2020 they could achieve 90%
of their goal by reducing their
emissions and the last 10% by buying
negative emissions by paying us for
example to pump the remaining 20,000
tonnes underground and but can this
technology really stop climate change in
its tracks the question is to what
degree can that be scaled up to really
have an impact on the global climate
because that's in the end what matters
for climate change right and I think
there I'm very skeptical I'm very
skeptical that these technologies for
removing co2 from the atmosphere can be
scaled up to a degree where they would
really have an impact on the global
climate there are other visions of how
we might manipulate the climate for
example ships that shoot seawater high
into the sky creating clouds that
reflect sunlight and counteract global
warming it's also conceivable that
particular types of chemicals could be
sprayed into the air sulfur particles
for example could bounce back the sun's
rays which could help cool the earth in
my view it's too early to utilize
methods like these we don't know if they
were used regionally or globally how
they might affect weather extremes and
the distribution of rainfall or droughts
and flooding co2 emissions are still
rising
worldwide 2016 was a record year a
development that directly contradicts
the Paris climate agreement solutions
are called for the only way we can
achieve a long-term stable climate is by
no longer emitting co2 which changes the
climate into the atmosphere and then to
deal with some of the impacts that are
innocents already locked in from past
emissions we can consider what other
approaches might help us achieve
and maybe in the end it will turn out
that they're not viable that
geoengineering technologies are not
viable but perhaps also it might turn
out that they can help us Pacific island
nations like Kiribati are already
threatened by climate change swift
action is needed if we had to prevent
such places being completely swallowed
by the sea in a few decades